[Applause]
happy Wednesday everybody oh what a
great night huh so Joe Biden Merrick
Garland the doj and special prosecutor
Jack Smith just did something nobody saw
coming they endorsed Donald Trump for
president hell they might have even
elected him outright how else could you
explain an indictment so lame and
overtly political that it's guaranteed
to Galvanize every Trump voter like
funnel cake at a stock car race there's
less meat on this indictment than a
turkey carcass in Joy behar's trash can
stelter has a better chance at winning a
wet t-shirt contest don't bother reading
it I can sum it up for you Donald Trump
disagreed with the election outcome
oh you thought there'd be more sorry
these are Democrats they don't have to
work hard when the media gives them
cover and yes there's this second part
to forget about the Hunter and Joe show
make news to conceal the real news yes
the doj and Jack Smith apparently
believed that Trump's thought crimes are
more Insidious than the international
racketeering gang known as the Biden
Clan instead they chase thought crimes
and if thought crimes were prosecutable
we'd all be screwed cat would be our
death row complaining about wearing
orange
but see we don't do thought crimes in
this country this isn't Canada there's a
reason the first amendment is first it's
the thing that makes our Constitution
and our nation exceptional that and ice
machines
First Amendment means you can think and
even say things that others find
objectionable like if someone says I
love Brian Kilmeade
it's wrong it's gross disgusting even
but you can't arrest someone for it this
also holds true for Donald Trump but if
it doesn't then you're next Trump adores
the protest at the White House on
January 6th things went bad that day a
collection of yahoos rushed the capital
and stole Nancy's laptop
hey by the way has anybody you know got
a copy of that hard drive because uh
imagine the stock tips on that one
but just because he endorsed the
original protest doesn't mean he's
liable for the actions of a horned
Shaman even Judge Judy when convict and
she thinks sideburns are illegal
look if endorsing that protest means
Trump's guilty that most democrats
should be in jail too does anyone recall
the 2020 Summer of Love at least 25
deaths 2 billion in damage a federal
courthouse set on fire a police station
destroyed in kamala's reaction promoting
a bail fund and asking for donations
setting fire to a federal courthouse
attacking the white house isn't that
like obstructing obstructing official
proceedings that's one of the charges by
the way obstructing official proceedings
or oops for short
that's right Donald Trump has been
charged with two counts of oops
that's almost as serious as being
charged with one count of whoops
but legally that's known as stacking
charges you know like Nadler does with
depends
but in layman's terms it's
they throw the kitchen sink at them but
Biden just banned kitchen sinks
take this charge conspiracy against
rights Jack Smith who is every wild-eyed
Professor with Library breath and a BLM
bumper sticker literally had to reach
back to Civil War times for this charge
it's a law designed to keep the Klan
from suppressing the black vote in the
late 19 late 19th century I mean this is
a bigger stretch than when Tyrus does
yoga
what Smith gonna charge Trump with next
felony witchcraft the casting of spells
hey let's throw Trump in the Potomac to
see if he sinks or floats
meanwhile the liberal judge who's been
randomly selected to oversee the case
sent all 11 defendants from January 6 to
prison and for several of those
defendants prosecutors didn't even seek
prison time but she still put him behind
bars
and instead of spitting the media just
swallows one of if not the most
significant case in United States
history it is up there with Dred Scott
it is up there with Brown versus Board
of Education this is the gravest
political crime since secession from
time to time America faces threats from
Monsters who want to destroy our
democracy that happened in 1861 Pearl
Harbor 1941 911 2001 Donald Trump
threatening to do it all again but even
more effectively saying he's going to
Institute a presidential dictatorship
that we may assume is going to take our
democracy away quick someone call MSNBC
they need more people on screen
yeah
it's the world's ugliest yearbook
verbally because so-called media can't
be seen attacking free speech so they
call Free Speech something else bottom
line Stacy Abrams Hillary Nancy Joe all
denied electoral outcomes Obama
challenged his opponents ballot access
signatures in Illinois and there is in
this indictment no evidence Trump did
any more than that deny the outcome so
since our justice system is currently
operating like a Tijuana traffic court
it's really about the next election
winning a case against the Republican
New York and DC is just so much easier
than ballot harvesting but it tells you
what happens when you dare to fight it
upsets those in power this indictment
sends a message that there will be no
Trump or another one like him ever and
by waiting until the Archer stuff came
out that pulled the curtain back and
showed us how this machine operates they
went too far because they thought they
could now if you're inside this story
you don't get the story but if you step
outside of it you see it's just a
political machine trying to crush its
Challengers now I'm not here to tell you
how to vote but as I said at the top
whether they realize it or not I think
Joe and Merrick the doj and Jack just
did
tonight's guests his way with words
entertains the rabble and has him
undefeated at Scrabble novelist and
literary critic Walter Kern
he's killed more people than covid
former CIA operative Mike Baker
she's like an above ground pool
refreshing but often found in bad
neighborhoods monsters contributor
captain
[Applause]
finally Mars sent Rovers to explore him
my massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion
[Applause]
Walter I have a question for you but I
just want you to speak your mind about
this what are you thinking right now
about all of this the timing is
interesting the charges are based on
mind reading what are your thoughts
you know they historians like to call
America the American experiment uh and
by that they mean we try things but I'm
afraid the American experiment is about
to blow up the laboratory uh this is a
little too much we're now going to have
12 people rather than 80 75 million
decide our elections
um and and it concerns me but what
concerns me more is that we now know
what American Presidents can't do they
can't say I was robbed yeah uh you know
they can do that in pro wrestling they
can do that in every other sport but
they can't say I was robbed what they
can do is they can put you know hundreds
of thousands of Japanese citizens in
concentration camps in World War II they
can start wars looking for weapons of
mass destruction that aren't found they
can you know do all sorts of things but
they can't say I was robbed right that's
going to be illegal uh so at least we'll
have crossed one crime off the list
it concerns me that about half of
America right now is looking for a way
out of America
and it's not a good thing it is true
that like the guy didn't start one war
but you know what he thought he got
ripped off
so he's in trouble I thought Mikey and
look you look as rugged as ever uh thank
you and I'm concerned that we seem to be
saying that starting a war is a bad
thing is that what you're saying Walter
it's bad for your business oh yeah it's
good for his business
it's bad for my son yeah you know great
point was made by Ann Coulter the media
is obsessed with January 6 because it's
the first mob we've ever seen that
wasn't left wing
yeah I uh I guess the the part that that
fascinates me the most right is because
I've always the problem I've always had
with Donald Trump is is
that it's a self-inflicted wound that he
usually engages in right so his behavior
on January 6th the things that he that
he did he could have done it better
there was I agree the indictment is full
of nothing right there's nothing there
but
you know the former president has a
tendency to create situations that are
unnecessary if he would just step if he
could Reign himself in but that's why he
got elected well I got elected because
he fights it's like you can't turn that
you can't turn the faucet off exactly
and that's that's the problem that that
we have right because again I I the
policies were great right again I'm a
small government guy you know worry
about National Security worry about the
borders uh financial responsibility if
we could find you know folks interested
in that but I guess the part again that
I find Most Fascinating about this whole
story is the randomly selected judge yes
who previously prior to being a judge
worked for the most Democrat linked law
firm in this country right and linked to
barisma link to Prisma uh and also a
place where Hunter Biden was of counsel
yes right for five years yeah and
they're trying to the media is just
trying to blow that one over right
there's no connection there just like
everything else involving the president
President Biden's son and so there's
there's so many problems here but deep
down I keep I'm disappointed because I
keep thinking that we could have avoided
a lot of this chaos if president Trump
could have just rained himself in and
been a little bit more disciplined but I
don't disagree with your point which is
that's why people voted for him I I have
to disagree that no matter what you do
they're going to come after you yeah it
wouldn't have they didn't it wasn't
January 6th they impeached him before
that for a phone call Kat what's your
take on I know you're a legal scholar uh
well yeah everybody thinks they're a
legal scholar now yes so I might as well
hop on well you watched a lot of La law
growing up I don't know what that is
uh I'm just I I kept reading it I was I
was pretty confused because
I guess they have to prove that he knew
he lost the election and was saying all
this stuff anyway
I don't think that he thinks he lost
first of all I know that he would never
say that he lost because he doesn't even
say that about golf yeah exactly no how
are how are they intending to prove this
I I really don't understand and I have
the same concerns as everybody does as a
First Amendment absolutist regardless of
how you feel about any of this that it
should be concerning to see this case
that basically hinges on what I believe
is pretty clearly free speech last word
Tyrus what are your thoughts
I'm trying I always try to take things
and look in my perspective like if I
went to work every day and somebody did
something to me to try to make me lose
my job the entire four years I worked
there every day Gutfeld put something in
my desk some drug paraphernalia a kidnap
victim like just non-stop got together
with half the office I don't have lunch
with and they all voted to have me fired
yes I would be not trusting any of them
come Christmas time with gifts yeah and
I think everyone in here would be like
yes I would not believe one thing that
came out of that other side after what
they did for you for four years
literally everything they could possibly
do with no criminal connection he was
Putin's that he was Putin's life
partner then he was a dance partner in
North Korea yes you know like he can you
be a and a life partner at the
same time it's a graduation okay what
I'm saying he graduated you know what
I'm saying it started out he was a side
chick but then they got to know each
other they had so much in common and and
one day he just came home told his wife
listen it's Trump's time he just he just
gets me and then the irony is they stop
having sex they stop well that's usually
what happens when you communicate yeah
so you guys know
and then one day something happens and
you don't believe it because you had
four years of everything you did was
destroyed ruined his entire presidency
was one big coup and then you have the
temerity to say he had no right to think
the election was rigged exactly he had
no right that's like literally I mean
you look at anyone's life take yourself
out of the presidency they're going to
get a conviction that's what they're
going to do doesn't well they've got 73
counts on them now they just need one
and that's all they're after but the
coup is the work is not done so and
they're sitting this this is now sitting
in DC
yeah I'm saying you know regardless of
whether he's convicted or not he's going
to get elected president because the
American people see it I said it last
night I'll say it again he changed
things yeah
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else